Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 42. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe über Wissenschaft, über Forschung, aber auch über die Lehre und die Bildung. Und ja heute soll es genau darum gehen, wir wollen uns mal ein bisschen nochmal das Thema Bildung anschauen und insbesondere auch den Aspekt der Digitalität unseres Zeitalters hierbei nochmal mit reinholen. Wir hatten dieses Thema schon mehrfach gestreift, vor allem in der 22. Ausgabe mit Jürgen Handke. Und werden auch bestimmt heute einige Aspekte davon nochmal aufgreifen. In gewisser Hinsicht handelt es sich hier um ein verwandtes Gespräch. Und zunächst einmal begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, Jörn Loviscach, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Habe ich es richtig ausgesprochen?
Perfekt.
Super. Das geht bestimmt nicht jedem so.
Nein das hört man in vielen Varianten.
Das kenne ich auch selber ganz gut. Ja Herr Loviscach, wir sind jetzt hier in Bielefeld an der Fachhochschule in Bielefeld.
In dem Ort, den es gar nicht gibt.
In dem Ort, den es angeblich gar nicht gibt, aber ich kann das hier nochmal bestätigen, dass es da auch andere Meinungen gibt.
Wir haben das aus Pappe aufgebaut, damit es sehr plausibel aussieht.
Ja nach Pappe sieht es hier aber nicht aus. Ich kam hier rein und war ganz beeindruckt, ein niegelnagelneues Gebäude ist hier geschaffen worden, also ein komplett neuer Standort, wenn ich das richtig sehe?
mhm (bejahend).
Jetzt so vor 1-2 Jahren richtig?
Etwas mehr als einem Jahr bezogen, hat etwas länger gedauert, weil wir dieselbe Firma hatten, die auch in Berlin am Flughafen gebaut hat.
Ach wirklich?
Welche von denen?
mhm (bejahend).
Darf ich den Namen nennen, weiß ich nicht. Eine von denen.
Okay. Na gut, aber es scheint ja am Ende dann doch funktioniert zu haben. Auf jeden Fall merkt man, dass das hier eine Architektur ist, die sich in gewisser Hinsicht so an den Bedürfnissen versucht auszurichten.
Unbedingt mit Einschränkungen. Also die Sitzbänke in den Fluren sind vielleicht etwas hart und die Steckdosen fehlen leider. Wenn einer einen leeren Akku hat. So was passiert.
Damit konnte ja keiner rechnen.
Nein, nein. Steckdosen, wer braucht heute so was? Ist doch alles drahtlos.
Genau. Ja wir wollen heute ein bisschen reden über die Lehre und die digitale Lehre. Sie haben da einen eigenen Ansatz gewählt, der noch nicht unbedingt jetzt so verbreitet ist. Bevor wir darauf kommen würde ich aber ganz gerne mal so ein bisschen Ihren eigenen Hintergrund nochmal ein wenig hinterfragen. Sie sind ja auch im Prinzip so ein bisschen alter Hase in Digitalien, wenn ich das mal so unterstellen darf. Wann fing es denn an?
Oh zu Teenagerzeiten. Die ersten Computer waren dann selbst gebaut, so ein Z80 Drahtigel.
Also Anfang der 80er Jahre?
Das muss Anfang der 80er Jahre gewesen sein, genau. Da ging es noch um Musik. Lauter Computer zum Musik machen. Der erste Computer war einer, der ein analoges Schlagzeug angesteuert hat, digitales, nein elektronisch nachgebildetes Schlagzeug angesteuert hat, das war so der erste Computer.
Aha, komplett selbst gebaut oder?
Der war komplett selbst gebaut.
Also Bausätze gab es ja nicht.
Das waren noch Zeiten, nein da gab es keinen Bausatz für. Das war wie gesagt Drahtigeltechnik.
Wie kam es dazu? Ich meine, was bringt einen dazu sich mit sowas...
Man konnte ja keinen kaufen.
Aber ich meine, was bringt einen dazu, sich sozusagen, also was war die Verheißung? Was war sozusagen das Interesse? Man hätte ja auch Fußball spielen können
Faszination, die Faszination der Synthesizer. Jean-Michel Jarre und so weiter zu der Zeit. Die elektronische Musik war alles unbezahlbar. Also heißt das selbst bauen.
Also sozusagen von der Musik zum System?
Von der Musik zur Elektronik. Die Musik war der Auslöser und dann zur Elektronik. Was interessant ist, weil ich kann meinen Studentinnen und Studenten heute immer noch alles mögliche vormachen mit Transistoren und Operationsverstärkern, hat sich nicht viel geändert an der Analogelektronik. Und der Computer war nötig zum steuern vom Ganzen.
Also war sozusagen so ein bisschen das Mittel zum Zweck?
War Mittel zum Zweck.
Man möchte ein Ziel erreichen und stellt fest, Computer könnte helfen.
Ja ist unabdingbar an der Stelle gewesen sogar.
Wie ging es dann weiter?
Ganz anders mit einem Physikstudium. Weil ich habe mir dann überlegt, soll ich Elektrotechnik studieren und habe mir das mal genauer angeguckt, was man da so studiert und habe mir gesagt, wozu? Das habe ich ja schon hinter mir und habe dann Physik studiert.
Auch erfolgreich?
Naja gut, ich habe es mit einer doch bestbenoteten Promotion dann abgeschlossen die Physik.
Okay, man unterstellt ja immer, dass man solche Studiengänge dann auch abbrechen muss, wenn man später wirklich erfolgreich sein will.
Genau. Wann ist man erfolgreich? Wenn man Stanford oder Harvard abgebrochen, erst dann ist man erfolgreich. Insofern war ich nicht erfolgreich, ich habe bis zum Ende studiert.
Und dann gab es so einen Schritt in den technischen Journalismus bei Ihnen.
Ja, weil zu der Zeit waren die theoretischen Physiker jetzt nicht so gefragt, um es mal vorsichtig zu sagen. Und ich hatte parallel schon angefangen, für Computerfachzeitschriften zu schreiben. c't-Magazin und so was. Und daraus hat sich eben dann ergeben, dass ich mit dem Journalismus weitergemacht habe. Erst so ein kurzes Zwischenspiel in München bei der MC, die hatten ein Relaunch mit dem Apple Power PC. Der kam seinerzeit raus. Aber der Verlag hat dann nach ein paar Monaten gesagt, okay das mit dem Relaunch war doch keine so gute Idee, machen wir dicht. Und ich bin dann nach Hannover gegangen zur c't.
Ins journalistische Epizentrum würde ich mal unterstellen.
Ja zumindest was die Computer angeht.
Also der Heise-Verlag ist ja eigentlich die erfolgreichste Publikationsplattform für technischen Journalismus in Deutschland. Genießt ein hohes Ansehen bis heute.
Wobei erfolgreich kann man auf verschiedene Arten messen, aber gilt als das vertrauenswürdigste Vehikel an der Stelle. Was die Umsätze angeht und was die Auflagen angeht, müsste man nochmal genauer nachgucken.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, gibt es ja immer noch, ist ja auch schon mal eine Aussage.
Ja stimmt.
Aber am Ende hat es Sie in die Forschung getrieben oder ist man dann berufen worden?
Forschung ist an der Fachhochschule ein großer Begriff, nennen wir es lieber Lehre und Forschung.
Ja okay.
Zur Fachhochschule zurück nach Bremen. Was heißt zur Fachhochschule zurück, zur Fachhochschule nach Bremen als Professor für Computergrafik. Und nach neun Jahren dann nach Bielefeld als Professor für Ingenieurmathematik und technische Informatik.
Computergrafik? Hat sich das jetzt sozusagen automatisch aus der journalistischen Tätigkeit heraus ergeben?
Eigenwillig nicht?
Weil mit Musik hat es ja eigentlich auch nichts zu tun.
Ja weil ich bei c't dann Richtung Multimedia abgewandert bin und auch so Diverses selbst programmiert habe in die Richtung. Ist es dann plötzlich die Computergrafik geworden.
Und war das dann sozusagen so eine einfache Entscheidung zu sagen, oh ja klar Lehre und so passt ja super? Ist das im Prinzip dasselbe wie Journalismus?
Ehrlich gesagt war das ganz anders. Ich habe einfach bei c't gekündigt und habe mir dann was neues gesucht. Weil so Job als stellvertretender Chefredakteur einer so großen Redaktion, das ist jetzt nichts, was man so unbedingt ganz lange machen will. Es geht doch sehr auf die Gesundheit.
Schlaucht?
Schlaucht.
Und dann die Lehre versprach, nicht zu schlauchen?
Das wusste ich schon, dass das auch schlauchend ist, aber es ist schon was anderes, wenn man weiß, in einer Stunde laufen die Druckmaschinen an und jeder Stillstand kostet so und so viel 100.000 Euro. Das ist schon eine andere Nummer in der Fachhochschule.
Aber ist das so im Kopf vergleichbar? Also fühlt man sich sozusagen als Tech-Journalist auch sicherlich zum Teil auch als Erklärer, aber man hat ja nicht so einen unmittelbaren direkten Kontakt zu seinen Lesern bzw. man fragt ja auch nicht die Ergebnisse danach ab.
Oho, ganz im Gegenteil. Also gerade bei c't war es wirklich heftig. Man muss, und das ist heute auch immer noch so, man muss wirklich jeden Satz sauber nachrecherchieren, im Zweifelsfall sitzt man eine halbe Stunde an einem einzigen Satz, weil wenn das nicht stimmt, gibt es so was um die Ohren von den Lesern. Also das trainiert einen schon. Das ist eine andere Situation für die meisten Leute, die an Hochschulen unterrichten. Da kann man jeden Unsinn erzählen, es erfährt ja keiner, solange man es nicht auf YouTube stellt. Da kommt man mit sehr viel durch und da gibt es auch die wildesten Schoten, die mir so zugetragen worden sind von diversen Standorten, was alles für ein Unsinn erzählt wird. Das war bei c't definitiv anders. Da gab es nicht die Möglichkeit, ungestraft Unsinn zu publizieren.
Okay, und war denn das Feedback der Studenten dann vergleichbar?
Hach die Studenten haben ja im Allgemeinen keinen Vergleich. Wenn die im ersten Semester ankommen ganz frisch, was wissen die, wie es anders sein könnte? Also das Feedback der lokalen Studentinnen und Stundeten ist überschaubar, um es mal so zu sagen. Das Feedback kommt aus dem Netz dann. Dass die Leute sagen, oh jetzt verstehe ich es endlich mal, danke danke.
Von welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt bei dem Engagement in Bremen?
Das ist bist, müsste ich aber nachgucken, bis 2000, irgendwie neun Jahre bis 2000 so um den Dreh.
Und was hat man da so unterrichtet, wenn es um Computergrafik geht? Also was war da so der Schwerpunkt? Ging es um Hardware oder um Anwendungsentwicklung?
Hardware kommt ja im Zweifelsfall aus den USA. Wie man mit der Hardware umgeht, also die typischen Grundlagen der Spieleprogrammierung. Wie stellt man Drehungen dar, wie beschreibt man Drehungen mathematisch, sollte ich sagen. So was. Wie stellt man Texturen dar? Wie projiziert man Sachen? Wie beschreibt man dreidimensionale Objekte? Da gibt es so einen riesigen Katalog an grundsätzlichen Methoden, die man mal alle gesehen haben muss, die man alle mal ein bisschen anprogrammiert haben muss.
Aber das war ja sicherlich zu dem Zeitpunkt jetzt noch kein so verbreiteter Studiengang oder keine so verbreitete Spezialisierung?
Der Studiengang hieß digitale Medien oder Medieninformatik. Das war zu dem Zeitpunkt schon sehr en vogue Medieninformatik. Hat eigentlich da mal ganz anders angefangen. Kann sich heute keiner mehr dran erinnern. Makromedia Director, so CD-Roms produzieren. Im Zweifelsfall sogar mit Lernsoftware, wo man dann Schritt für Schritt durchklickt und was erzählt bekommt in den alten Tagen, auf CD-Rom dann vertrieben. So hat das eigentlich mal angefangen mit diesen Studiengängen Medieninformatik. Und ist dann mehr und mehr in Richtung Internet gegangen, Webtechnik.
Mit dem Wechsel nach Bielefeld sind Sie dann aber auch auf ein anderes Lehrmodell umgeschwenkt?
Ja zufälligerweise, absurderweise. Ich hatte ein paar Studentinnen, Studenten als ich hier angefangen habe, die musste noch die Mathematik nachholen, weil sie die im ersten Durchlauf nicht geschafft hatten. Waren dann also in einem höheren Semester. Hatten das Problem, dass die Mathematik, die ich angeboten haben, stundenplantechnisch kollidiert hat mit deren Stundenplan des höheren Semesters. Und dann habe ich einfach gesagt, okay ich hole mir irgendeinen gebrauchten Tablet-PC, iPad gab es da zu der Zeit gar nicht. Das war ein gebrauchter Windows Tablet-PC, den ich mir dann geholt habe, irgendwie für 300 Euro oder so was. Habe das als meine Tafel benutzt und das Ergebnis auf YouTube hochgeladen. Also dann die Veranstaltung aufgezeichnet auf diese Art, ziemlich simpel.
Und was lief auf dem Tablet? Also war das jetzt wirklich nur so ein Schreibblock?
Ja sozusagen. Einfach so ein normaler Windowsrechner mit Stift und dann habe ich einfach Journal benutzt, die Standard-Anwendung darauf, die Microsoft mitliefert zum Schreiben und ein gratis Programm zum Screenrecording, um den Bildschirm dann als Video und was ich sage als Video aufzuzeichnen.
Also sozusagen noch keine Talking Heads.
Nein das ja sowieso bei mir nicht.
Keine Videoaufzeichnung von einem selber?
Nein nein, sowieso bei mir nicht. Ein paar Monate später habe ich dann gelernt, dass es in den USA einen gibt, der heißt Salman Khan und der macht so was auch mit schwarzem Hintergrund und Unterschrift.
Was war der Effekt davon? Also was war jetzt überhaupt der Hauptgrund, es aufzuzeichnen?
Der Hauptgrund war, dass ich Nachzügler hatte, die irgendwie versorgt sein wollten und mir ist eingefallen, dass ich das doch ganz simpel machen könnte ohne großen Aufwand.
Und die haben sich das dann angeschaut?
Die haben sich das angeschaut und ein paar tausend Andere haben sich das angeschaut und immer mehr haben sich das angeschaut.
Weil es auf YouTube stand?
Weil es auf YouTube stand.
Und was war das für ein Effekt?
Auf mich dann? Das ist natürlich so der übliche Effekt der sozialen Medien, Motivation. Man sieht dann, oh da geht was. Da könnte nochmal mehr gehen.
Weil ich im Gespräch mit Lehrern aller Art, die ihre Lehre betreiben, wenn man die dann darauf anspricht, warum sie denn bitte das was sie dort eh machen nicht aufzeichnen und veröffentlichen. Merke ich gibt es einen riesigen Katalog von Bedenken, warum man denn das nicht tun könne, wolle etc. Das scheint Sie ja gar nicht zu belasten?
Das kann an meiner Vergangenheit liegen. Wenn man bei c't gearbeitet hat, kennt man ziemlich heftige Reaktionen des Publikums, vielleicht liegt es daran. Weil es kommen heftige Reaktionen. Also es kommen viele Reaktionen von Leuten, die sagen, toll danke schön, Sie retten meinen Bachelor. Aber es kommen auch total heftige Reaktionen, du schuldest mir 50 Minuten meines Lebens oder gerade heute kam etwas von wegen, unsere Lehrerin hat uns dieses Video gezeigt in der Klasse. Ich habe nichts verstanden, was für ein scheiß Video. Damit muss man leben können.
Ja, also wenn man sozusagen durch dieses Stahlbad der Internetkommentarkultur marschiert ist, dann ist das einem egal?
Ja so richtig egal ist es auch nicht, aber man kann es schon abschütteln. Ich kann es schon einschätzen dann.
Das heißt man multipliziert das sozusagen mit einem anderen Faktor? Kann man das so sagen?
Ja genau. Man hat so einen Lautstärkeregler und kann dann mal so 50 Dezibel rausnehmen sozusagen aus dieser Art Kommentar.
Aber man kann dann auch schon verstehen, dass es da Vorbehalte gibt? Weil Leute, die sagen wir mal durch dieses Stahlbad jetzt nicht so gegangen sind.
Ja unbedingt. Und vor allen Dingen die Kritik ist ja auch schon heftig. Und auch c't-mäßig. Das habe ich bei c't gelernt, wie gesagt jeden Satz muss man nachrecherchieren. Und das ist jetzt bei den Videos genauso. Wenn ich was erzähle, da habe ich vorher drüber nachgedacht, sonst erzähle ich das nicht.
Also einfach mal so daherreden?
Keine Chance. Man kann nicht einfach mal irgendeinen Mist daherreden, das gibt was auf den Deckel. Und das kostet im Endeffekt auch Zeit. Also diese Videos zu produzieren – Mitschnitte ist geschenkt - dass man sich vorher ordentlich informiert, über das was man erzählt. Das kostet richtig Zeit.
Aber man würde ja jetzt eigentlich auch erwarten, dass das bei jeder Vorlesung getan wird?
Ja. Es soll … ganz sicher, das machen auch garantiert alle. Anekdotisch höre ich doch da so, nicht unbedingt von meiner eigenen Institution hier, aber so aus den Weiten der Bundesrepublik, doch, dass das vielleicht nicht immer der Fall ist.
Also kann es auch sein, dass Leute sich sozusagen allein deshalb schon vor einer Aufzeichnung und einer Veröffentlichung fürchten, weil sie Angst haben, dass ihre Fehler widerlegt werden, derer sie sich vielleicht selber bewusst sind oder vielleicht auch nicht bewusst sind? Ist das auch so ein Teil der Ablehnung?
In der Tat. Das befürchte ich, dass das ein großes Problem ist. Es gibt vielleicht ein noch wesentlicheres Problem, Urheberrecht. Was ich mache ist ja handgezeichnet von vorne bis hinten, auch irgendwelche Diagramme sind dann alle handgezeichnet. Wenn jetzt, wie man das meistens eben macht an den Hochschulen, wenn man so einen Satz PowerPoint-Folien hat mit zusammenkopierten Diagrammen und Bildern, keine Chance. Den kann man natürlich nicht frei ins Internet stellen.
Ja es sei denn man hat vorher geklärt, dass es sich hierbei um Materialien handelt, die entsprechend frei sind, was sie wahrscheinlich in den seltensten Fällen sind.
Ja viel Spaß damit. Da hat man lange zu suchen, bis man das hingekriegt hat.
Aber wäre das nicht ein Ansatz? Ich will es jetzt nicht zu weit treiben, aber sicherlich ist diese Copyright-Problematik ein weiterer Aspekt. Also wir hatten jetzt die Kommentarkultur, also die Reaktion des Netzes, dann dieses, oh Gott ich werde widerlegt, habe ich vielleicht nicht recht? Man weiß so, ich habe genug recht, um das was ich hier vortrage vertreten zu können, auch wenn ich weiß, dass ich vielleicht nicht in diesem 98/99/100%-Bereich sozusagen noch Verbesserungen anbringen könnte.
Good enough.
Aber es ist so good enough, i got my point. Aber meistens sind es ja dann genau diese 2%, auch denen sich dann so diese Kommentare auch beziehen. Dann werden die anderen 98% mal geflissentlich ignoriert.
Woran dann offenbar wird, dass man es doch jetzt nicht wirklich so genau weiß.
Genau, aber wenn man jetzt diesen Punkt überschritten hat, wenn man einfach sagt, okay alles klar, entweder ich lebe mit diesen 2% oder ich bemühe mich halt so extrem, den zumindest so nahe zu kommen, dass man mir mindestens unterstellen kann, dass ich mich ausreichend bemüht habe. Also dass das was dann da eben noch moniert wird, man dann eben auch runterregeln kann. Aber wenn man es jetzt sozusagen professionell aufzieht und sagt, okay, ich möchte jetzt gerne meine Vorlesungen, meine digital aufgezeichnete Vorlesung, perfektionieren, insofern als dass ich jetzt nicht unbedingt immer alles von Hand zeichne. Weil jetzt möchte ich auch gerne in ein Unterrichtsmaterialfundus greifen, den es vielleicht aber so in der Form einfach noch nicht gibt, fragt man sich natürlich, warum gibt es den nicht? Und könnte man nicht in dem Moment auch damit anfangen, ihn selber aufzubauen? Und unter entsprechenden Nutzungslizenzen verbreiten, so dass eben andere Lehrkörper auch darauf zurückgreifen können.
Ja, wie findet man dann irgendwas wieder? Also es gibt ja so einige Versuche, nicht nur einige, sondern recht viele Versuche, Repositorien oder zumindest Linksammlungen aufzubauen zu solchen Materialien. Aber das ist schon schwierig. Also wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle, ich bräuchte jetzt, was weiß ich, in der Biologie bräuchte ich von irgendeiner besonderen Zelle irgendeinen Bestandteil, einen bestimmten Querschnitt, bis ich das gefunden habe, mit der richtigen Lizenz und so weiter, ist es ja viel leichter, es einfach gerade zu zeichnen. Ich finde das viel charmanter zu zeichnen, weil dann sieht man nämlich auch, wie ich denke, wo fange ich an, wo höre ich auf. Was sind für mich die wichtigsten Punkte, die wichtigsten Landmarken sozusagen, mit denen ich so eine Zeichnung anfange? Woran orientiere ich mich? Woran merke ich, dass meine Zeichnung schief gegangen ist auch? Was muss passen in der Zeichnung? Wenn die Zeichnung da fertig erscheint, habe ich diesen ganzen Lerneffekt nicht.
Man bildet sozusagen auch noch den Gedankenprozess selbst mit.
Ja definitiv. Also ich finde es viel besser in handgezeichnet. Aus ganz vielen Gründen.
Was sind weitere Gründe?
Also die ganzen didaktischen Gründe. Man sieht es eben im Entstehen. Man ist gezwungen mitzudenken. Man hat die Zeit, auch mitzudenken. Es ist nicht auf einen Schlag da. Man hat die Zeit, mitzudenken. Man kann sogar noch als Lehrer dann die Leute erst mal bitten, machen Sie mal gerade selber, wie sieht das denn im Prinzip aus? Wie müsste diese Kurve aussehen und dann können wir das erst mal diskutieren. Oder ich zeichne mehrere Kurven hin, zum Beispiel wenn es so ein Diagramm ist, bei dem keine Ahnung Spannung in Abhängigkeit von der Zeit, wie müsste es denn im Prinzip aussehen? Wie müsste es aussehen, wenn wir einen großen Kondensator nehmen? Wie müsste es aussehen, wen wir einen kleinen Kondensator nehmen und so weiter. Das Ganze wird formbar, es wird flüssig, es ist nicht in Stein gemeißelt.
Trotzdem denken wir mal diesen Gedanken mit den Unterrichtsmaterialien so nach, weil sagen wir mal in dem Moment, wo ich genau das erkläre und wo es an der Stelle genau um das geht, dann ist es nachvollziehbar, dass man das sozusagen auch wieder von Grund auf vorlebt. Weil das ist sozusagen die Essenz. In einem anderen Vortrag, in einer anderen Vorlesung, in einer anderen Darbietung möchte ich mich vielleicht nur auf die in diesem Themenfeld erarbeiteten Grundlagen als solche beziehen, ganz andere Dinge erarbeiten. Möchte aber sozusagen, um das zu veranschaulichen, um diese Abstraktionskonzeption als solche nochmal mit reinzubringen, das einfach nur nochmal als Verweis verwenden. Dass man sagt, hier das ist das was der Herr Loviscach gezeichnet hat, das ist alles sehr hübsch ausgestaltet und dann sieht man, da gibt es die und die und die Struktur und jetzt fange ich quasi dort an und mache den nächsten Schritt. Dann wäre es doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, wenn man auch darauf zugreifen könnte. Sind denn die ganzen Sachen, die Sie veröffentlichen, so frei nutzbar?
Ja ich bin ja ein bisschen vorsichtig an dieser Stelle. Das ist zwar eine CreativeCommons-Lizenz, die ich da drauf setze, aber eine non commercial, dass jetzt zum Beispiel nicht die Verlage hergehen können und sagen, ach das bauen wir mal bei uns ein. Das scheint ja aktuell zum Trend zu werden, dass die Großverlage sich existierende OpenSource, CreativeCommons-Materialien nehmen und dann was drumherum stricken und dann damit Geld verdienen. Das finde ich nicht ganz so lustig muss ich gestehen. Insofern bin ich ganz glücklich, dass ich das seit Anbeginn ein NC drauf geschrieben habe, non commercial. Dass es also nur nicht kommerziell verwendet werden kann.
Und da gibt es da bei der CreativeCommons-Lizenz auch noch diese schöne Option des ShareAlike.
Klar das ist dann auch, ShareAlike non commercial, das habe ich da drauf.
Aber ich meine, wenn man es in dem Moment sozusagen kommerziell nutzbar macht, aber quasi ein ShareAlike verpflichtend macht, würde man ja dann quasi die darauf aufbauenden Materialien gleichfalls freistellen. Wäre ja auch nochmal ein Ansatz, dass man so diesen viralen Aspekt einer Lizenz nutzt und sagt, ja das könnt ihr schon machen und ihr könnt da auch gerne ein Buch draus machen, das könnt ihr auch gerne verkaufen, aber ihr müsst halt die Materialien auch kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen und all das, worauf es aufbaut, muss auch selber wiederum weiter verwendet werden können.
Ja das habe ich ja diese Lizenz, CCby NC,SA. Das ShareAlike ist denke ich schon eine bittere Pille für die Verlage, dass die es dann nicht so leicht einbauen können.
Könnte aber auch durchaus eine Motivation sein für eine andere Vorgehensweise, um entsprechenden Materialien dann einfach mal … ich meine, wenn man sagt, okay wir bauen auf dem auf, was andere machen, aber wir produzieren auch wiederum was, worauf andere drauf aufbauen können. Ich meine die Erfahrung zeigt ja aus vielen Bereichen, dass man durchaus in so einem Segment eine Polposition einnehmen kann und sagen kann, okay wir waren hier einfach die ersten und selbst wenn andere auch noch auf unserer Arbeit basieren und kopieren etc., wir werden immer diejenigen sein, die hier den kreativen Motor füttern und daraus uns eine Stellung im Markt schaffen. Aber den Sprung machen vielleicht manche nicht so gern.
Wow, das ist ja … als Google kann man sich das erlauben und als Facebook. Ich meine, das ist ja bei denen Gang und Gäbe, dass sie Sachen freigeben, weil sie die führenden sind und das damit dann auch noch zementieren, indem sie das freigeben. Das ist natürlich für einen Einzelkämpfer an einer ostwestfälischen Fachhochschule eine andere Nummer. Also ich fände es ärgerlich, wenn andere Leute damit Geld verdienen, muss ich gestehen.
Okay. Was ist denn da jetzt bei herausgekommen? Also was hat sich aus diesem ersten Ansatz, ich nehme einfach mal das auf, was ich sowieso tue, stelle das ins Netz, dann hat es eine gewisse Verbreitung gefunden. Inwiefern hat denn dass jetzt den Unterricht als solchen angefangen zu formen? Hat sich das Unterrichten dadurch geändert?
Definitiv.
Oder war das in gewisser Hinsicht ihr Plan? Was hat sich geändert?
Dass ich mir beim zweiten Durchgang gesagt habe, halt das ergibt doch keinen Sinn, dass ich das jetzt nochmal aufnehme, das haben wir doch schon. Und dann bin ich eben auf Flip Teaching aka Inverted Classroom gekommen, dass ich dann den Studentinnen und Studenten gesagt habe, wisst ihr was, da gibt es doch die alten Aufzeichnungen, die guckt ihr euch an und wir machen stattdessen Aufgaben. In der Zeit, die im Stundenplan als Vorlesung steht, machen wir eine Gruppenübung definitiv. Es gibt nicht mehr eine Vorlesung, auch wenn sie im Stundenplan steht.
Und was haben die Studenten dann gesagt?
Hat sich keiner beschwert soweit. Und wir haben dann eben Gruppenübungen gemacht, die ich interessanterweise ja auch wieder aufzeichen. Das heißt jedes Jahr kommt weiteres Material dazu, bei jedem Durchgang, jeder Veranstaltung. Weil die Aufgabe, die ich dann mit den Studentinnen und Studenten bearbeite, auch die nehme ich dann wieder auf. Also die Aufgabenstellung, dann drücke ich auf Pause, gehe rum, gucke was passiert. Dann lasse ich die Aufnahme weiterlaufen, erzähle wieder ein bisschen was für die Aufnahme und für die live Anwesenden. Drücke wieder auf Pause, gehe wieder rum und so weiter. Dann wird eben so aus 90 Minuten Vorlesungszeit nochmal halbe Stunde bis 45 Minuten Video. Mit den Anteilen, die frontal passieren. Und der Rest ist weggeschnitten.
Lassen Sie uns das nochmal ein bisschen konkreter fassen. Nehmen wir vielleicht mal ein Thema heraus, was es so jetzt auch gegeben hat. Worum ging es, worum handelt eine normale bereits einmal vorher aufgezeichnete Vorlesung, mit denen sich die Studenten jetzt erstmalig befassen sollen? Nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Gut fangen wir mit der Mathematik an, was einfaches, muss ja nicht sofort Wind- und Wasserkraft sein. Nehmen wir Mathematik, was die meisten vielleicht noch kennen. Klassisches Beispiel an der Fachhochschule wäre, es geht um eine bestimmte Sorte Differentialgleichungen. Wie wird eine bestimmte Sorte Differentialgleichungen gelöst? Sagen wir lineare, homogene Differentialgleichung.
Wie lang ist denn diese Vorlesung, die aufgezeichnet wird, die vom Tablet kommt, mit den selbst gemalten Zeichnungen? Wie lange dauert die?
Für das Thema wäre das nicht der komplette 90 Minuten Block, das wären dann 20-30 Minuten vielleicht. Für dieses eine kleine Spezialthema.
Ein Häppchen.
Ein Häppchen genau.
Das wäre aber dann sozusagen eine Aufgabe, mit der sich die Studenten erst mal befassen oder kommen dann gleich 2/3/4?
Ach so, na die haben sich zu Hause natürlich dann hoffentlich mit den Videos vorbereitet, 90 Minuten oder so was. Viele Häppchen hintereinander. Viele Themen hintereinander. Und in der echten Präsenzveranstaltung kommt dann eine Aufgabe nach der anderen. Erst eine Aufgabe, um mal gerade anzutasten, ist das überhaupt verstanden im Prinzip? Und dann immer mehr und mehr in die Tiefe. Meist eigentlich auch improvisiert diese Aufgaben. Ich gucke einfach, was geht und was nicht geht und improvisiere dann Aufbauen live. Je nachdem was möglich ist. Also mit zunehmender Tiefe dann die Aufgaben.
Aber ich wollte nochmal diesen Prozess nachvollziehen. Also es gibt jetzt eine oder mehrere Vorlesungen, die bereits vorher existieren. Die dann vielleicht in ihrer Gesamtlänge 90 Minuten Material ausmachen.
Genau, entspricht ja derselben Veranstaltungszeit, weil es war ja ursprünglich mal genau diese Veranstaltungen.
Okay, das heißt das geht dann einfach per E-Mail an die Studenten raus und sagt, hier nächste Woche das ist das Thema, setzt euch mal schön mit einem Kaffee aufs Sofa und haut euch das mal rein.
Genau.
Dann machen die das, gehen wir mal davon aus, dass sie das tun. Was ist dann der nächste Schritt für die Studenten? Ich meine, okay, anschauen...
In die Veranstaltung zu kommen hoffentlich.
Und da dürfen die auf jeden Fall auch immer kommen oder gibt es dann sozusagen nochmal einen Nachweis zu führen, dass man das, was man da auch gesehen hat, in gewisser Hinsicht verstanden hat?
Das wäre schön, wenn man diesen Nachweis fordern dürfte. Hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen ist das alles sehr schwierig. Insofern ist das dann Vertrauenssache.
Weil das ist ja in dem Gespräch mit Jürgen Handke Teil seines Modells, dass sozusagen die Zulassung – das ist vielleicht ein zu starkes Wort – aber sagen wir mal eine Qualifikation.
Dass man noch einen kleinen Test macht online.
Genau, dass man sozusagen sagt, okay ich habe das in gewisser Hinsicht auch verstanden, das fällt jetzt hier weg. Ist das ein Problem, dass es wegfällt?
Das ist ein Problem ja für die Selbstkontrolle der Studentinnen und Studenten insbesondere ist das ein Problem. Weil die gar nicht so genau wissen, ob das jetzt läuft oder ob das jetzt nicht läuft. Also wir haben eben in Nordrhein-Westfalen doch strenge Vorschriften, was die Anzahl der Prüfungen angeht und die Anzahl der Prüfungsleistungen pro Modul. Nämlich = 1 und nicht mehr. Und auch Anwesenheitspflicht ist ein Problem in Nordrhein-Westfalen. Also ich kann auch keine Anwesenheitspflicht fordern dann in der Präsenzveranstaltung. Das ist schon schwierig sagen wir mal unter diesen Randbedingungen.
Aber bei der normalen Vorlesung hätte man das können?
Auch nicht, nein nein. Das können wir alles gar nicht mehr fordern. Bei einer normalen Vorlesung darf ich auch keine Anwesenheitspflicht fordern. Gerade beim Flip Teaching wäre es ja wirklich spannend, wirklich jeden da zu haben und von jedem/jeder dann auch was zu sehen persönlich. Aber das können wir hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen nicht fordern.
Allein weil jetzt das Reglement sich eigentlich an etwas ganz anderem ausrichtet. Von daher passt eigentlich …
Ja. Weil das Reglement davon ausgeht, Vorlesung, da vorne steht einer/eine vor 500 Leuten und ist auch egal, ob man kommt oder nicht. Das kann ich nachvollziehen. Aber jetzt bei diesem Format ist es natürlich nicht so geschickt.
Das heißt hier wäre es eigentlich ganz angemessen, wenn man mal über dieses Reglement nachdenkt?
Das wäre schon sehr geschickt.
Wird darüber diskutiert?
Nicht wirklich, nein. Das ist zu sehr ein Spezialfall. Ja also schön wäre es tatsächlich, solche elektronischen Quizze zu haben vorab auch, wenn an sie denn machen dürfte, wie Jürgen Handke das macht in Marburg. Im Prinzip habe ich so was. Ich habe letztes Jahr vier MOOCs gemacht. Diese massiven offenen Onlinekurse mit Oncampus Mooin heißt ja die Plattform. Einer davon ist auch ein Mathematik-MOOC, zwei sind zur Windenergie, einer ist zur Mensch-Maschine-Interaktion, aber in der Tat könnten meine Studentinnen und Studenten, wenn sie wollten, einfach diesen MOOC belegen und da sind dann auch tatsächlich Fragen eingebaut elektronischerseits, an denen man feststellen kann, ob man es nun verstanden hat oder nicht. Aber natürlich tut das keiner, das ist ja mehr Aufwand, wenn man nun auch noch nach dem Genuss, das ist schwierig.
Das unterstellt immer so ein bisschen, dass es gar keine Motivation gibt, zu lernen. Ich meine, das trifft ja sicherlich nicht für alle Studenten zu?
Nein, es ist der Matthäus-Effekt. Also die Leute, die in der ersten Reihe sitzen und sowieso zu jeder Veranstaltung erscheinen und nachher die 1en schreiben, die gucken sich die Fragen an und bearbeiten auch welche davon. Und die Leute mit Problemen sind im Zweifelsfall auch diejenigen, die das nicht machen. Die diese Chance nicht nutzen, das ist total traurig.
Wie kann man dem entgegenarbeiten?
Da suche ich auch irgendwie was. Also man müsste so als Ausgleich zu diesem Matthäus-Effekt - wer hat, dem wird gegeben, aus dem Matthäus Evangelium - als Ausgleich zu diesem Matthäus-Effekt müsste man so einen Robin Hood-Effekt haben, so einen Umverteilungs-Effekt. Aber den scheint nirgendwo zu geben in den Bildungswissenschaften. Es gibt ein paar Leute, die danach suchen, aber es ist total schwierig.
Wie soll der funktionieren?
Ja das frage ich mich eben auch.
Ich meine, was soll der Effekt davon konkret sein?
Dass man tatsächlich mal die Leute mehr fördert, die Probleme haben, als dass die Leute, die keine Probleme haben, dann obendrein noch profitieren.
Also dass sie sich selbst mehr fördern dadurch, weil sie Probleme haben oder dass man erkennt, wen man zu fördern hat?
Das ist relativ schnell zu erkennen, wen man zu fördern hat. Dass dann auch wirklich was passiert. Dass man in der Lage ist, tatsächlich alle am Schlafittchen zu nehmen und zu sagen, so jetzt setzen wir uns mal zusammen und üben verflixt nochmal das mit den Differentialgleichungen erster Ordnung, linear homogen, bis das sitzt.
Also da sind wir jetzt wieder an dem Punkt angelangt, wo die quasi diese Prüfung, die Zwischenprüfungen, die ja nicht erlaubt sind, zumindest nicht in Nordrhein-Westfalen, nicht in diesem aktuellen Reglement, im Prinzip sehr hilfreich sein könnten. Weil sie nicht in dem eigentlichen Sinne eine Prüfung sind mit, hier kommt das finale Ergebnis und jetzt stellt sich heraus, ob man das gemacht hat oder nicht. Sondern eigentlich mehr so eine Meilensteinprüfung ist quasi, wo man für sich selber feststellen kann, habe ich das jetzt gemacht oder nicht.
Ein formatives Assessment, wie es so schön heißt.
Oha.
Ja die Bildungswissenschaftler brauchen dann immer so ihr Fachchinesisch. Ein formatives Assessment im Gegensatz zum summativen Assessment. Das summative Assessment ist dann die Klausur am Ende. Das ist das unausweichlich, summativ das Ergebnis. Und vorher kann man formativ noch eingreifen, formen.
Gut, aber ich möchte trotzdem von dem hochmotivierten Studenten ausgehen, der vielleicht schon hat und dem dann noch gegeben werden kann. Aber vielleicht auch noch nicht hat, und dem trotzdem gegeben wird. Man nimmt also jetzt sozusagen diese Kurse auf. Würden Sie sagen, dass die Wirkung eines digital aufgezeichneten Vortrags anders ist, als der den man so in der typischen Präsenzveranstaltung gibt? Wirkt er mehr? Wirkt er weniger? Fehlt da was? Gerade wenn irgendwie kein Talking Head vor einem herum hampelt, ist das etwas, was so eine Vorlesung vielleicht auch gut gebrauchen könnte, aber jetzt hier einfach nur aus praktischen Gründen erst mal weggelassen wird? Oder ist das eigentlich genau das gleiche oder hat es vielleicht sogar noch mehr Vorteile?
Ehrlich gesagt würde ich vor allen Dingen erst mal sagen, dass der Effekt eines Vortrags und der Effekt einer Onlinevorlesung insgesamt ziemlich marginal ist. Den größten Effekt hat man, wenn man sich selbst hinsetzt und nachdenkt, Aufgaben bearbeitet, Probleme bearbeitet. Also mit so einem einfachen Vortrag, ob live oder aufgezeichnet, da kriegt man vielleicht mal so eine Idee, man hört so ein paar Begriffe, hat vielleicht hin und wieder auch mal das Heureka, die Glühbirne geht an im Kopf. Aber richtig viel Lernen passiert da nicht. Man lernt denke ich eigentlich erst dann, wenn man Sachen in die Hand nimmt und damit arbeitet, vernünftig damit arbeitet. Das als Vorbemerkung. Dann gibt es natürlich schon Unterschiede zwischen Video und live. Das Video kann ich anhalten, das Video kann ich mit halber Geschwindigkeit abspielen, das Video kann ich auch mit doppelter Geschwindigkeit abspielen bei gleicher Tonhöhe. Das scheinen die Studentinnen und Studenten zu lieben in den Tagen vor den Klausuren, sich das ganze Semester nochmal im doppelten Tempo anzutun im Schnelldurchlauf.
Im Schnelldurchlauf. So wie bei Dieter Thomas Heck damals.
Ja genau, so hört sich das dann ja auch an. Das kann man in der Liveveranstaltung nicht machen. In der Liveveranstaltung sehe ich die Chance, dass man konzentrierter ist, vielleicht konzentrierter ist. Es ist ja schon, in einer regulären Vorlesung mit 500 Leuten, so, dass in den letzten 20 Reihen alle das Notebook auf haben und auf Facebook und WhatsApp sind, auf dem Tablet dann auf WhatsApp sind. Aber zumindest die Leute vorne in den ersten Reihen denke ich sind noch so halbwegs dabei. Wenn ich eine kleine Veranstaltung habe, dann ist denke ich schon ein bisschen mehr Konzentration drin in der Liveveranstaltung, aber auch nicht allzu lange. Also was es da an Studien dazu gibt, nach 20 Minuten oder so ist einfach die Luft raus mit der Konzentration, wenn da vorne einer steht und was erzählt. Es wird hoffentlich besser, wenn man dann tatsächlich Flip Teaching macht und Aufgaben macht, dass alle an den Aufgaben sitzen und nachdenken müssen in Partnerarbeit typischerweise dann.
Oder wie sich das so ergibt, wieviele Leute gerade in den Reihen sitzen. Nicht alleine, sondern in irgendwelchen Clubs zusammensitzen, diskutieren, an Aufgaben arbeiten. Da sollte das besser funktionieren mit der Aufmerksamkeit, dass man etwas länger dabei bleibt. Und was dann eben auch besser funktioniert, das merke ich, beim Flip Teaching, wenn man Gruppenarbeit macht, dass die Leute eben nicht abdriften und auf Facebook oder sonst wo sind oder irgendwelche Spiele machen. Gibt es auch, einige sind halt wirklich so hart drauf, dass sie auch dann noch das Tablet rausholen und irgendwelche Rollenspiele machen. Aber das sind doch sehr viel weniger, als das was man sonst so sieht in einer regulären Veranstaltung.
Das heißt es gibt mehr Engagement? Kann man das so sagen?
Mehr Engagement ja.
Warum ist das so?
Weil man selbst was tun muss. Weil ich rumlaufe. Ich glaube, das wäre schon eine Dreistigkeit, wenn ich rumlaufe und gucke und alle säßen da und würden WhatsApp-Nachrichten beantworten. Ich glaube, das traut sich noch keiner. Vielleicht noch nicht. Also es hat einen gewissen Vorteil, dass doch viele Geräte dann in den Taschen verschwinden, außer die zum mitschreiben. Viele Studentinnen und Studenten haben tatsächlich inzwischen ein Tablet zum schreiben.
Es gibt ja viel Gerede und Gedeute darum, wie sehr sich denn die Generationen denn nun angesichts des digitalen Wandels auch selbst in ihrem Verhalten ändern. Spürt man da was oder ist das eigentlich macht es keinen Unterschied?
Das ist schwierig, so über die Jahre, Jahrzehnte …
Also ist eine andere Erwartungshaltung oder eine anderer Akzeptanz?
Die Erwartungshaltung, Akzeptanz das ist alles so anekdotisch schwer zu beantworten. Das Lesen scheint extrem nachzulassen. Also die Abschlussarbeiten, die ich so vor 10 Jahren bekommen habe, da wurden doch tatsächlich noch richtig Bücher zitiert und Zeitschriftenartikel zitiert und heute findet man doch wesentlich mehr Internetquellen, Videos werden zitiert statt Bücher. Das ist schon zumindest anekdotisch etwas, was mir auffällt.
Ist das was schlechteres oder ist das nur was anderes?
Im Zweifelsfall sind diese kurzen Formate ja doch flacher. Ein Buch hat eben dann doch Fußnoten oder Randbemerkungen, geht in die Tiefe, normalerweise mehr in die Tiefe als so ein Video. Also es ist schon eine flachere Art, sich das Wissen zu verschaffen. Hat nicht so viele Nuancen denke ich.
Na gut, wenn man ein einzelnes Video mit einem ganzen Buch vergleicht, aber das ist ja dann vielleicht auch so ein bisschen Äpfel und Birnen. Ist es dann nicht vielleicht so, dass man sagt, das was ich normalerweise aus einem Buch herausziehe, das hole ich mir jetzt aus 10-20 vielleicht 100 verschiedenen Videos, die unterschiedliche Aspekte abdecken?
Ja so ist es dann nicht. Es ist dann wirklich dann ein Video, da habe ich das gesehen und ein anderes Video für das nächste Thema. Also es ist jetzt nicht, dass man in die Breite geht dann an der Stelle und sich Sachen zusammensucht, sondern good enough, das hat mir jetzt gereicht. Irgendwie habe ich es da jetzt zusammen gekriegt. Das ist gerade drastisch beim Programmieren in der Informatik. Sollte ich besser sagen, Programmieren, Informatik ist ja mehr als nur programmieren. Beim Programmieren ist es wirklich drastisch. Man sucht sich was zusammen, was man irgendwo gefunden hat im Internet. Funktioniert ja soweit. Wenn keiner genau hinguckt funktioniert es soweit. Dann ist auch gut genug. Warum das jetzt funktioniert oder wo es Probleme geben könnte, das muss man sich dann im Zweifelsfall gar nicht mehr angucken. Das ist schon eine etwas unschöne Art, eine sehr oberflächliche Art, die sich da mehr und mehr einstellt, ist mein Eindruck.
Ist das ein vorübergehender Trend? Oder ist das etwas, was einreißt? Ich meine, nicht alles was sozusagen abkippt, muss ja zwangsläufig immer weiter abrutschen.
Wie gesagt, ich kann es jetzt nur anekdotisch sagen, aber ich würde sagen, es ist tatsächlich etwas, was einreißt. Gerade als Ingenieurin, als Ingenieur muss man sich Gedanken machen, warum das jetzt funktioniert oder nicht funktioniert, was man da macht. Es darf nicht einfach so wie es da ist nur so gerade mal wie es steht und wackelt wie ein Kartenhause, gerade irgendwie funktionieren, sondern es muss solide sein. Und diese Solidität würde ich sagen über die Jahre, an denen ich lehre, diese Solidität geht verloren mehr und mehr.
Wodurch geht sie verloren? Also was ist …
Man kommt zu schnell an Lösungen.
Was ist die Ursache davon?
Ich glaube man kommt zu schnell an Lösungen. Man googelt einfach, ich brauche jetzt eine Schaltung, die dieses oder jenes macht. Ein Programm, das dieses oder jenes macht. Und das gibt es dann auch relativ schnell und dann ist auch gut. Sobald man gezwungen ist, Sachen selbst zu machen, ist das eine andere Nummer. Man muss es viel mehr durchdenken. Vielleicht gibt es zu viel, zu schnell. Ich musste meinen ersten Computer als Drahtigel zusammenlöten. Ich weiß heute noch die Maschinensprachebefehle auswendig von dem Z80, einige, nicht alle, aber einige. Und heute geht man in den Laden, holt sich ein Smartphone, wird schon irgendwie magisch funktionieren.
Da gibt es ja dieses schöne Internetkulturwort von Eminent Death of the Netpredicted, was schon so in den frühen 90er Jahren hervorgeholt wurde in Anbetracht des Wandels. Und jetzt kommen ja alle die, die das alles nicht mehr so verstehen und der Untergang ist nah. Gut man kann darüber diskutieren, ob der Untergang hier und da von irgendetwas schon stattgefunden hat, aber dass es trotzdem eine starke Vorwärtsbewegung mit viel Erkenntnisgewinn gegeben hat ist ja auch unbenommen. Also ist es jetzt sozusagen leicht, hieraus ein sich fortlaufend fortschreibenden negativen Trend herauszulesen oder gibt es im Prinzip Hoffnung?
Da muss ich glaube ich nochmal auf den Matthäus-Effekt zurück. Also es gibt die einen, die wie wild durchstarten. Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel gerade einen Studenten, der eigentlich aus dem Bereich Elektrotechnik kommt, erneuerbare Energien und der hat sich in zwei Monaten wie wild in JavaScript eingearbeitet, dass ich nur sagen kann, Hut ab, Wahnsinns Tempo, sehr sauber, sehr umfassend eingearbeitet. Es gibt einerseits die, die diese Quellen nutzen können und aus ganz vielen Quellen parallel schöpfen. Und damit extrem schnell, extrem tief arbeiten können, fundiert arbeiten können. Und es gibt eben viele andere Studentinnen und Studenten, bei denen die Gefahr besteht, dass die an der Oberfläche kleben bleiben, weil funktioniert ja irgendwie, wir kommen ja irgendwie durch.
Aber war das nicht schon immer so, dass man irgendwie gute und schlechte Studenten hatte?
Ja… Als …
Dass es immer welche gab, die so durchgekommen sind.
Als ich selbst studiert habe, habe ich nicht drauf geachtet auf diese Phänomene. Es wird durchs Netz natürlich noch viel einfacher. Also dieses gerade eben durchkommen, 4 gewinnt, alles gerade mal so zusammenstricken, das ist mit den ganzen Möglichkeiten, die das Netz bietet, natürlich einfacher geworden.
Da hatte man ja auch immerhin schon so die populäreren Plagiatsfälle. Das ist ja sozusagen das eine.
Auch das ist einfacher geworden ja.
Es ist aber auch einfacher geworden, das nachzuweisen. Also es ist ja sozusagen auch ein Wettrüsten im Betrügen und im Belegen des Betrugs, wo man nicht gut sagen kann, wie das so ausgeht, aber es ist nicht zwangsläufig so, dass man jetzt einfach leichter davonkommt, auch wenn es mehr Materialien gibt, aus denen man abschöpfen kann. Lassen sich ja dann im Zweifelsfall auch besser nachweisen. Ich versuche noch zu verstehen, inwiefern wir sozusagen dann hier auch auf dem richtigen Weg sind. Ich meine dieses inverted Teaching, flipped Classroom, wie auch immer man das nennen will. Also die Grundidee, wo man sagt, das was man normalerweise als Präsenz gehabt hat, nämlich das Vermitteln der Basisinformationen, tauscht quasi seinen Platz, indem man das Vermitteln einfach aufzeichnet. Das Datengrundlagenbasiswissen, was sich ja eigentlich selten ändert oder selten substantiell ändert.
Das wird aufgezeichnet, das nimmt man eben einfach so wahr, wie Leute das in zunehmendem Maße auch gewohnt sind, nämlich durch Video- oder Audioaufzeichnung oder beides und man konzentriert sich mehr auf das miteinander arbeiten, das miteinander lernen, die intensive, interaktive Auseinandersetzung mit der Materie. Klingt ja jetzt erst mal super. Ist das der Weg, den Sie auch allen anderen empfehlen würden? Oder denken Sie, das funktioniert nur in bestimmten kleinen Bereichen, wie Ihren, wo das passt, aber es passt an vielen anderen Orten nicht?
Doch, ich denke es geht in vielen Fächern. Bei mir ist es ja schon also quer durch die Ingenieurwissenschaften. Bei Jürgen Handke ist es in der Anglistik. Das wird in vielen Fächern gehen. Ich glaube ich muss an einer Stelle nochmal einhaken, das hatte ich eben schon gesagt, dieses Vermitteln, was man jetzt davorschaltet, die Rolle von diesem Vermitteln die schätze ich relativ gering ein. Das Wichtige ist tatsächlich, dass man sich hinsetzt und drüber nachdenkt, erst dann lernt man was. Und wir können die Veranstaltungszeit eben dafür nutzen, hinsetzen, nachdenken mit großer Konzentration, möglichst ohne dass der Rechner offen ist und das Handy daneben liegt. Das ist für mich der große Gewinn.
Wenn man das jetzt so ein bisschen als Modell für ein neues Lehren heranziehen möchte. Und ich lese das jetzt mal so ein bisschen aus Ihren Aussagen raus. Dass Sie sagen würden, wenn jetzt hier Kollege von Fachhochschule irgendwo reinkommt und sagt, Herr Loviscach das scheint ja ganz gut zu laufen, soll ich das auch mal machen? Dann wäre ja die Empfehlung wahrscheinlich so, ja klar mach mal, weil ist aus meiner Sicht gut. Jetzt ist es bei Ihnen so, wie auch bei Herrn Handke, da steckt sehr viel persönliche Erfahrung drin, auch sehr viel frühe digitale Prägung, auch gepaart mit dieser intensiven Auseinandersetzung damit und damit natürlich auch so ein tiefes grundlegendes Verstehen. Während es vielleicht vielen anderen nicht so geht. Und sie da auch eine gewissen Unsicherheit haben im Umgang mit den Mitteln. Wir hatten ja auch schon diese Randbedingungen, nicht wahr, das Stahlbad der Kommentarwelt, das ist ja auch nicht besser geworden.
Nein. Noch eine weitere Randbedingung ist, dass ich bei c't ja auch sehr viel illustriert habe, inoffiziell Art Director war. Also Zeichnen kommt dann auch noch dazu. Deshalb die selbst gezeichneten Geschichten.
Genau, also das sind Fähigkeiten. Also es ist einerseits eine soziale Fähigkeit, die man irgendwie erlernt haben muss. Es ist ein sagen wir mal Grundverständnis des Digitalen an sich, was einen schon nach vorne bringt, was vielleicht noch am ehesten zu verzichten ist an der Stelle. Und es ist eben sozusagen auch ein gewisser Wunsch, ein Wille da drin. Also es müssen mehrere Fähigkeiten zusammenkommen, die man jetzt nicht unbedingt als Kernqualifikation für eine pädagogische Ausbildung sieht derzeit. Wenn man jetzt sozusagen diesen Wunsch oder diese Erkenntnis, das Digitale kann helfen, das Umdrehen des Klassenraums ist im Prinzip eine effizientere Vermittlungsmethode, welche Konsequenzen müsste das haben für die Ausbildung der Lehrer? Also was muss sich sozusagen ändern? Wir hatten ja die Regulation auch schon angesprochen, aber was muss ich darüber hinaus auch in einer Ausbildung ändern, um solche Herangehensweisen auch weiter zu fördern und auch Leute hervorzubringen, die das mehr verinnerlichen?
Oh ja, ich kann jetzt nicht so richtig über die Lehrerausbildung sprechen, weil die kenne ich natürlich auch nur so aus zweiter Hand.
Das kann auch ein Vorteil sein.
Ja in der Tat. Was man so liest kann das auch ein Vorteil sein. Mir ist da jüngst ein Büchlein in die Hände gefallen, fünf Jahre Bastelstunde oder wie hieß das? Das las sich relativ recht katastrophal, was die Lehrerausbildung anging. Ich würde tatsächlich sagen, das Fachliche ist tatsächlich extrem wichtig. Wenn ich jungen Menschen insbesondere was erklären soll, dann muss ich wirklich genau wissen, was ich da tue. Und wie das derzeit läuft mit der Lehrerausbildung ist ja, dass die Lehrerinnen und Lehrer immer so beiseite geschoben werden, ihr seid ja nicht ernstzunehmen, wir lassen euch mal so mitlaufen, aber wir nehmen euch nicht so ganz ernst. Das ist vielleicht ein Problem. Ich hatte den Vorteil im Mathematikunterricht, persönliche Prägung. Ich hatte im Mathematikunterricht einen der beiden Autoren vom dtv-Atlas Mathematik. Inzwischen verstorben, den Herrn Dr. Söder.
Das hat mich nach vorne gebracht. Da war wirklich jemand, der wusste, was er wie macht. Der hatte total die Ahnung von Mathematik gehabt eben. Das ist eine extreme Prägung gewesen. Lustigerweise wo ich dabei bin, bei den persönlichen Prägungen, im Deutschunterricht hatte ich einen Romanautor. Auch das war da die Grundlage für den Journalismus. Lustigerweise, also durch diese Lehrer alleine. Weil diese Lehrer wirklich wussten, was sie getan haben, in Deutsch und in Mathematik. Was habe ich später im Leben gemacht? Deutsch und Mathematik.
Ja gut, ich meine das ist natürlich jetzt aber auch ganz unabhängig von der Vermittlungsmethode, dass man sich wünscht, dass Lehrer natürlich auch in ihren Bereichen sich auskennen.
Ja aber das ist die Grundlage. Und ich befürchte, ich habe eben zu viele andere erlebt auch, zu viele andere Lehrer, bei denen das sagen wir mal fachlich nicht ganz so brillant war, und das hat mich nicht allzu angespornt.
Ja gut, ich meine da könnte man auch sagen, dann ist ja die digitale Lehrmethode oder der Flipped Classroom dann eigentlich auch egal, weil wichtig ist, dass die Lehrer einfach nur wissen, wovon sie reden und wie sie das dann vermitteln ist dann egal.
Das ist Grundbedingung, ohne das ist alles nichts, würde ich erst mal sagen.
Setzen wir das einfach mal voraus. Also sagen wir mal, jemand nutzt seine …
Mal ganz utopisch setzen wir das voraus.
Na gut, aber setzt vielleicht seine Möglichkeiten nicht ausreichend ein. Ich meine jemand ist sozusagen in seinem Feld gut unterwegs und hat auch sagen wir mal die notwendige Motivation, diesen Job auch wirklich auszufüllen und nicht nur irgendwie abzusitzen. Was wäre ein empfehlenswertes Rüstzeug vielleicht in der pädagogischen Ausbildung, vielleicht auch als Angebot für Quereinsteiger oder auch nur ein Fingerzeig auf andere existierende Dinge im Netz, die man sich näher anschauen sollte, wenn man schon in diesem Beruf tätig ist. Was ist das Rüstzeug, was man sich noch mit aufsatteln sollte?
Ja für mich käme dann die Fachdidaktik, also wie ich bestimmte Sachen am besten erkläre oder welche Möglichkeiten ich habe, bestimmte Sachen zu erklären. Wie erkläre ich was eine Wurzel ist in der Mathematik? Welche Möglichkeiten habe ich, das zu erklären? Was gibt es an typischen Beispielen? Wie erkläre ich den Begriff Wahrscheinlichkeit in der Mathematik? Was kann ich alles heranziehen? Für wen nehme ich welche Erklärung? Wenn diese Erklärung schief geht, welche nehme ich dann und so weiter?
Ja gut, aber auch das gilt ja jetzt unabhängig von der digitalen Lehrmethode.
Auch das wäre unabhängig von der digitalen Welt. Wobei die digitale Welt dann natürlich den Vorteil hat, dass man sich orientieren kann, was es denn an Möglichkeiten gibt. Also das sehe ich dann tatsächlich, dass mir Leute schreiben, ich gucke mir jeden Tag, bevor ich es unterrichte, gucke ich mir an, wie Sie es erklärt haben. Also dass die Lehrer tatsächlich sich angucken, was man denn machen könnte. Das ist auch ein allgemeines Phänomen in den massiven offenen Onlinekursen. Da hatten MIT und Harvard jüngst noch eine Studie rausgebracht, dass bei denen 30% der Teilnehmer, die die Fragebögen beantwortet haben, dass 30% der Teilnehmer sagen, sie haben einen Hintergrund als Lehrende. Also es scheinen extrem viele Lehrende sich diese Kurse anzugucken und dann vielleicht hoffentlich auch was mitzunehmen darüber, wie man auf verschiedene Arten man Sachen rüberbringen kann.
Das heißt es könnte sein, dass wir gar nicht groß uns über irgendwelche pädagogischen Konzepte Gedanken machen müssen, weil die mehr oder weniger automatisch dadurch entstehen, dass in zunehmendem Maße digital Lehrende auf andere digital Lehrende treffen und sich eben im besten Sinne ihr Handwerk gegenseitig schleifen, indem sie sich sozusagen an den Konzepten anderer orientieren?
Zumindest was diese Fachdidaktik angeht. Und dann kommt ja noch diese persönliche Betreuung dazu. Das ist natürlich sehr schwierig. Das muss man wohl wirklich 1 zu 1 üben. Da sehe ich nicht, wie man das online hinkriegen kann. Wie geht man mit Schülerinnen und Schülern tatsächlich um. Gerade heute, wenn in der Klasse alles durcheinander geht.
Wie man die alle sozial eingefangen bekommt sozusagen?
Wie kriege ich die eingefangen ja.
Na gut, das Problem dürften ja Lehrer nun schon seit ewigen Zeiten haben.
Ja aber nicht in dieser krassen Mischung, die wir derzeit haben. Also ein Gymnasiallehrer früher, Gymnasiallehrerin, die durfte wahrscheinlich einfach sich vorne hinstellen und was erzählen und wurde da nicht irgendwie beschossen oder was auch immer mit Papierkügelchen. Und andere Geschichten. Das scheint ja heute schon anders zu sein.
Ja was sind denn sozusagen Ihre Erkenntnisse, wie man diese Lehrphase am besten durchführt? Was für Erfahrungen haben Sie denn da gemacht? Wie kriegt man denn die Leute unter Kontrolle?
Gut, ich habe jetzt ja nicht ganz die Probleme, die dann in der Brennpunktschule dann vorliegen. Also es geht ja schon gesittet zu an den Hochschulen, diese Probleme haben wir dann nicht mehr.
Na gut, aber man möchte ja sozusagen das Beste auch rausholen. Man möchte ja sozusagen auch, dass das Engagement im Prinzip immer nochmal 10% weitergeht, als es ohnehin schon ist. Was sind so wichtige Lehren, die Sie selber gezogen haben?
Ich denke auf jeden Fall natürlich ganz banale Geschichten. Freundlich bleiben, zuvorkommend sein. Alleine in die Knie zu gehen, nicht von oben herab zu agieren, sondern in die Knie zu gehen.
Auf Augenhöhe.
Auf Augenhöhe zu gehen, sich daneben zu stellen und einfach mal zuzuhören. Also das schlimmste, aber ich denke nicht, dass das jemand heute noch ernsthaft macht, aber das schlimmste ist natürlich, wenn an sich hinstellt und sagt, was sind Sie für ein Trottel, das kann doch jedes Kind. Klar, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Was fehlt Ihnen selber noch? Was ist denn unerreicht oder noch nicht erreicht? Oder sind Sie schon irgendwie restlos glücklich mit der Art und Weise, wie Sie es machen? Fehlt es an Mitteln, fehlt es an…?
Nein es sind nicht die Mitteln. Das Große Ganze stimmt für mich noch nicht. Ich sehe einfach in den Abschlussprüfungen… nicht Abschlussprüfungen, das soll ich nicht sagen, den Abschlusskolloquien, bei der Abschlussarbeit dann das Kolloquium, wenn man da dann mal fragt, wie würden Sie diese Differentialgleichung lösen oder zeichnen Sie doch mal einen Operationsverstärker Grundschaltung auf oder was ist Blindleistung, da erlebt sein blaues Wunder. Also die Halbwertszeit des Wissens, gerade der Grundlagen, ist erstaunlich kurz. Das finde ich sehr bedenklich, wenn Ingenieurinnen und Ingenieure dann rausgehen mit ihrem Titel und die ganzen Grundlagen nicht mehr sauber beherrschen. Das lässt mich nicht so ruhig schlafen.
Ja, was kann man dagegen tun?
Danach suche ich. Danach suche ich. Das heißt wir verlieren anscheinend in den höheren Semestern vor lauter Spezialthemen verlieren wir die Grundlagen, dass uns der Boden unter den Füßen wegbringt und alle nur noch freischwebend agieren. Ist total schwierig. Man könnte natürlich ganz dreist sagen, wir machen das so wie früher, es gibt eine richtige Abschlussprüfung, in der kommt alles vor, vom 1x1 bis zur hochkomplexen Schaltung. Ist vielleicht nicht in jedermanns Sinn und wird sich heute rechtlich auch nicht mehr machen lassen. Man muss ein bisschen mehr Augenmerk drauf haben. In allen Veranstaltungen, die es gibt, immer wieder das Augenmerk drauf richten tatsächlich, sind die Grundlagen da? Wenn man dann irgendwas erzählt über Energiespeicher, gerade nochmal vergewissern, dass die Leute wissen, wie das mit Ladung und Energie und Spannung und so weiter im Prinzip zusammenhängt. Und dass man da nicht über die Köpfe hinwegredet.
Gibt es ja noch ein paar andere Vorschläge, wie man sozusagen andere digitale Errungenschaften der 80er und 90er Jahre hier auspacken kann, Stichwort Spielorientierung. Jetzt werfe ich das einfach mal so in den Raum, was wäre denn, wenn man sozusagen die Prüfung ersetzt durch ein intelligent geführtes Textadventure, also so eine Art intellektuelles Labyrinth, in dem man dann so ein bisschen Detektivarbeit mit Grundlagen leisten muss, und sozusagen auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise sein Wissen kombinieren muss. Sagen wir mal sehr viel mehr praxisorientiert. Nicht nur das Abfragen von, weißt du das, weißt du das, weißt du das, kannst du mir das erklären? Zack zum Stichwort X konntest du mir das erklären, deswegen hast du jetzt den Stempel, ab jetzt darfst du alles vergessen. Sondern dass man vielleicht eher hingeht und die digitalen Möglichkeiten dahingehend nutzt und sagt, okay du baust jetzt hier wirklich interaktiv was zusammen, aber die Anforderungen bessern sich. Du kannst auch sagen wir mal noch ein sehr viel besseres Ergebnis erzielen, als nur alles zu wissen, indem du die Dinge besser zusammenbringst.
Oder überhaupt, dass vielleicht die letzten 20% hin zu einer Bestnote überhaupt nur dadurch zu erreichen sind, dass man eben kombinatorisch rangeht und dann in dem Moment versucht, diesen Prozess so ablaufen zu lassen, dass hier sein kreativer Geist gefragt wird, der nur funktionieren kann, wenn die Grundlagen auch wirklich vollständig durchdrungen sind.
Das ist natürlich …
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen Science Fiction.
Das ist ein bisschen Science Fiction und sehr aufwendig. Ich meine in mündlichen Prüfungen kann man so was ansatzweise versuchen, aber in 20 Minuten geht das auch nicht wirklich gut. Ja projektbasiert. Ich meine ich hatte bei meinem ersten MOOC, bei Udacity hatte ich so was versucht. Da hatte ich in jeder Einheit wirklich so ein kleines Projektchen. Also wie bringen wir jetzt Apollo vom Mond zurück? Oder wie bauen wir ein – wie sagt man denn auf deutsch – wie bauen wir ein Antiblockiersystem fürs Auto? Dass man sich jeweils da so durchhangelt. Und von der Mathematik über die Physik bis zur Programmierung dann alle Themen behandelt. Kann man tun, fände ich auch sinnvoll. Würde natürlich einiges an Umstrukturierung bedeuten.
Was ja derzeit sehr populär ist sind diese Escape Room Situationen, wo man sozusagen in so einen Raum gemacht wird und die Zeit läuft.
Kommt man raus.2
Man kommt halt einfach nicht raus. Ich meine, wenn man sozusagen die ganze Fachhochschule sozusagen in einen großen Escape Room umbaut und sagt, bevor ihr hier nicht genug kreativen Geist aufgebracht habt und diese Dinge innerhalb einer bestimmten Zeit zu lösen, kommt ihr hier nie wieder raus.
Genau, bevor ihr nicht einen ordentlichen Wechselrichter selbst aufgebaut habt, kommt ihr hier nicht raus.
Der dann irgendwas anderes treibt, was dann überhaupt erst … also sozusagen auch so diese Kaskadierung der Aufgabe. Wo man auch immer sehen kann, oh ich muss hier bei Schritt 1 irgendwas schonmal vollkommen vergeigt haben, weil ich komme hier bei 3 noch nicht mal drauf, was überhaupt sozusagen die Aufgabe sein könnte.
Gut ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man das voll elektronisch dann haben muss. Könnte man natürlich auch als Planspiel oder als 3D-Adventure, wäre dann sehr aufwendig.
Sicherlich, da kommt dann vielleicht die Expertise in Computergrafik mit rein.
Genau, da kommt die Computergrafik wieder rein. Wobei heute ist das alles viel einfacher. Man hat einfach Unity und sagt einfach, mach. Das Ding macht das meiste ja von selbst. Im Prinzip, ich meine was wir hier in meinem Büro auch vor uns sehen, diese Projekte und Arbeiten haben wir natürlich schon drin. Wobei ja also hier die selbstgebauten Wasserturbinen und die selbstgebauten Anemometer. Wobei man da eben auch sieht bei solchen Gruppenarbeiten, die Beteiligung der verschiedenen Leute in der Gruppe ist doch auch verschieden und es ist schwer, das gegeneinander abzuwägen und vor allen Dingen ist da auch immer wieder die Tendenz, es so gerade mit Spucke zusammenzukleben sozusagen, programmiertechnisch oder mechanisch, wird schon irgendwie, Hauptsache es läuft jetzt einmal. Ohne dass man genau verstanden hat, warum es jetzt läuft oder warum es vielleicht so keine tolle Idee ist.
Ist immer schwierig bei den Projektarbeiten, dafür zu sorgen, dass wirklich das Fundament da ist. Also man müsste Projektarbeiten extrem … was heißt man müsste, man muss Projektarbeiten extrem gut begleiten als Lehrender, um immer wieder dafür zu sorgen, dass das Ganze so geerdet ist. Wüsste ich jetzt, was ihr da tut, warum denn so, warum nicht anders? Was macht eigentlich diese Zeile im Programm, wenn folgendes passiert und so weiter. Man müsste ständig eingreifen und alle wieder sozusagen auf den Pott setzen, um klar zu machen, dass die Grundlagen bitte stimmen müssen. Dass das nicht einfach nur so ein Gebastel wird. Dasselbe Problem wird man sicherlich auch bei elektronischen Lösungen haben. Wenn man jetzt so ein elektronisches Planspiel macht, ein 3D-Adventure daraus macht. Wie sorgt man dafür, dass wirklich immer wieder die Grundlagen da sind, dass sauber gearbeitet wird?
Unlösbares Problem, oder vielleicht ein Gedanke, den man verfolgen könnte?
Ich denke drüber nach und denke drüber nach, habe noch keine Lösung. Das heißt nicht, dass es unlösbar ist, aber auf jeden Fall ein schwieriges Problem und ein bisher noch zu selten beachtetes Problem. Es gucken immer alle auf die Noten. Das ist so ein Problem von unserem Bologna. Modul, Abschluss für das Modul, nächstes Modul, Abschluss für das Modul und nach einem Jahr ist alles vergeben und vergessen. Man kann sich an nichts mehr erinnern.
Vielleicht zum Schluss nochmal der Versuch, den Blick in Dinge, die sich vielleicht gerade entwickeln, auch zu werfen. Gibt es etwas, was Sie bei anderen Lehrern, Universitäten, Hochschulen oder überhaupt generell nur auch im Netz oder an anderen Orten beobachten, was so Ihr Interesse weckt? Wo Sie denken, da könnte sich vielleicht was interessantes draus entwickeln, was auch für meine Arbeit wichtig sein könnte?
Auf jeden Fall spannend finde ich die Megaspaces. Also wie soll man sagen, der inszenierte Gerätekeller sozusagen. Früher hatte man so was selbst. Da hatte man eine Bohrmaschine, man hatte einen Lötkolben, man hatte ein Oszilloskop, habe ich alles noch. Meine Studentinnen und Studenten haben das nicht mehr. Die haben keine Bohrmaschine, keinen Lötkolben, keinen Oszilloskop, das ist total traurig. Da studiert man was mit Elektrotechnik und hat nie im Leben zuvor einen Lötkolben in der Hand gehabt und weiß auch gar nicht, wozu ein Oszilloskop ist oder gar ein Voltmeter gut ist. All das und noch einen 3D-Drucker und was man sich sonst so vorstellen könnte so zur freien Verfügung und dann, Leute jetzt bastelt mal was. Das Megaspace finde ich schon sehr schön, ist natürlich in Deutschland wieder der Horror, was die Rechtslage angeht. Was ist, wenn sich jetzt einer in den Finger bohrt oder wenn einer den Lötkolben auf sein Notebook fallen lässt und was auch immer, Drama, Drama, geht ja alles gar nicht.
Wenn man das in den Griff kriegen würde, rechtlicherseits, betreuungsmäßigerseits so eine postmoderne Bastelstube.
In der Fachhochschule selber zu machen?
In der Fachhochschule selber zu machen. Ich meine, so habe ich selbst ja angefangen. So habe ich Interesse daran gewonnen.
Es gibt hier kein Labor?
Es gibt Labore, aber das sind natürlich sozusagen Hochsicherheitstrakte aus Sicherheitsgründen. Nur unter Aufsicht und nach langer Einweisung.
Aber was es eigentlich mal bräuchte ist so ein Keller mit Sofas, wo man einfach …
… wer am lautesten und mit am meisten Funken schweißt, der ist vorne?
So einen Bastelkeller.
Genau so was.
Das heißt so ein bisschen, wir haben das jetzt nicht gesagt, aber auch so ein bisschen der Mut zum Regelübertritt und mal versuchen …
Ja so was anarchisches.
Was auch noch so ein bisschen wehtut sozusagen.
Anderswo gibt es das ja nicht. Beim MIT da stellen die Studis regelmäßig irgendeinen Laster oben aufs Dach oder was auch immer. Das ist sicherlich höchst verboten, aber trotzdem machen die das und finden es lustig. Wir erstarren in allen möglichen Sicherheitsvorschriften, was so was angeht.
Ja. Man ist nicht mutig genug?
Man ist nicht mutig genug. Ich meine, als ich angefangen habe zu basteln, immer schön Schaltnetzteile am offenen Herzen repariert und so. Natürlich habe ich mir 2-3 mal auch einen ordentlichen Stromschlag geholt.
Aber trotzdem ist ja die Zahl der Elektrotechnikstudenten, die an ihrer eigenen Forschung gestorben sind, doch überschaubar oder?
Ist überschaubar. Klar, man muss vorsichtig sein, das war keine gute Idee seinerzeit. Da hätte ich ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein müssen. Aber so mit 14/15 ist man da etwas unbedarft an der Stelle. Aber es wäre auf jeden Fall spannend, so was zu haben. Vielleicht muss man dann ganz viele Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter engagieren, die alle vorsichtig gucken, dass da auch keiner irgendwas komisches macht, dass da richtig gebohrt wird, ohne dass es einem um die Ohren fliegen kann und so. Aber selber machen, das merke ich bei meinen Studentinnen und Studenten, wenn die hier ankommen, die haben noch nie was selber gebaut vorher.
Na wäre das dann nicht vielleicht einfach mal eine gute Voraussetzung? Dass man einfach sagt, wer nicht irgendwie hier einen Roboter durch den Laden laufen lassen kann, der selber gelötet wurde.
Braucht erst gar nicht anzufangen.
Das gibt es hier natürlich schon.
Das gibt es natürlich hier schon. In einigen Studiengängen werden dann diese Mindstorms-Roboter benutzt zum Beispiel.
Ja aber so als Aufnahmeprüfung.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich Stichwort Matthäus. Die Kinder aus den reichen Elternhäusern, die haben dann schon den kompletten japanischen Roboter und die anderen …
Na gut, einen fertigen Roboter kaufen und selber einen bauen, sind nochmal zwei unterschiedliche Dinge.
Ja okay, da hat man zumindest die teuren Bauteile schon mal, die besseren Servos und die bessere Fernsteuerung und den besseren Microcontroller und was auch immer. Ist schwierig.
Suchen Sie sich denn Ihre Studenten aus?
Können wir nicht. Das ist zu schwierig. Also Aufnahmeprüfungen oder so keine Chance. Es gibt in einigen Studiengängen Numerus Clausus, was überhaupt nicht prickelnd ist, weil da hast du plötzlich das Gymnasium auf einer Stufe mit der Fachoberschule. Die Leute von der Fachoberschule können bei tatsächlich schon löten und die aus dem Gymnasium haben ein bisschen mehr Mathematik gehabt, aber auch schon wieder vergessen. Das ist alles so schwer zu vergleichen, wenn dann plötzlich alles mit einer Note über einen Kamm geschoren wird. Finde ich auch nicht schön.
Wir stellen fest, es bleibt eine Herausforderung.
Oh ja.
Aber es ist nicht hoffnungslos.
Nein noch habe ich die Hoffnung nicht aufgegeben.
Das ist gut. Herr Loviscach vielen Dank für die Ausführungen …
… zu Ihrer digitalen Lehre. Ja und ich sage auch wieder vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Das war Ausgabe Nummer 42, ein Gruß an Douglas Adams an dieser Stelle.
Gerne.
Auch von mir.
Genau und wir schreiten dann auch bald weiter zur nächsten Zahl. Bis dahin sage ich nochmal, tschüss und bis bald.